so I think the idea of like a workshop
based class hands-on class like that's
what's becoming trendy in education at
least that MIT right now is like
bringing it back to mind in hand they
won't work if students don't bring
anything to workshop or like have
anything ready so that's why the first
you know two three days of class were
very very information intense to bring
them up to the point where they had a
script that they could actually read
aloud at the table read or that they
would have a scene they could storyboard
mm-hmm I don't know how how was it
leading the workshops because I get kind
of let you guys take over for those yeah
I mean I think I it was great i mean i
think we couldn't have done what we did
if they hadn't come to the class with a
portion of a script that they could
storyboard or do some sort of storyboard
work on I think maybe in the future you
might think about having well I don't
know having setting it up so that
there's instruction about say
storyboarding and in examples and kind
of models then have them do that and
then have them return for the critique
yeah as opposed to trying to compress
all of that into one yes so but again
that's that requires more time mm-hmm so
yeah my my only workshop workshops are
great because it means that you rely a
lot more on stuff that you sort of just
know and can talk off-the-cuff about and
don't have to prepare long lectures
which is fantastic but that requires
that you actually are just natively an
expert in that the nice thing about that
is that you can reduce the time that you
spend speaking and increase the time
that they spend working and and speaking
and I think the earlier that you get the
students talking and doing things in a
workshop the quick more quickly there
they like realize that it's not a
lecture and that they're not just going
to sit there and absorb that they have
to actually do something
so you had like people reading their
scripts from the beginning of your
workshop there was no easing into it it
was pretty much just like all right this
is the script that someone so submitted
last night okay come up and read it for
us yeah yeah and and then like they get
over their nerves and they just do it
and and and and then and then you roll
into I mean the other heart the hard
thing about doing that is giving
feedback in a workshop is tough because
you have to I mean you can't just be
like great job and you know go sit down
that was great that you did it but we're
not going to give you any like
constructive criticism but you have to
do it in such a way that it's not ego
destroying and that applies for any of
the any of the stuff you know so it's I
mean it's hard to do especially if
you're hosting because they're your
scent you're commenting on their tone of
voice there you know delivery style like
a twisted the way they talk you know the
way there yeah so it's a tricky thing to
like get to sort of err on the side of
being a little bit softer than you
probably then you it's also sorry sorry
I just going to say it's also
interesting to get them I think it just
for my you know basic pedagogical
experience because I did teach creative
writing for a while you know it's nice
to get them to get students as you said
talky doing peer work or they're
critiquing each other yeah so there
isn't just this authority figure that
has all the answers there's also this
innate sense that we all have and
students have of what's working and
what's not because they're our audience
members too and they have that audience
sensibility actually a really important
thing was to establish that the medium
in which we were working had no
established best practices and that was
something that I tried to emphasize a
lot and say you know I very strong
opinions on what I think is good hosting
and what isn't but at the end of the day
you do what you want as long as you can
justify it to me you know like you can
take or leave my advice on how I think
you should edit the section but if you
want to stick with what you have and
you're able to
right out but an A for effort you know
like that's fine as long as I see that
they're like consciously processing
their own personal taste yeah yeah um
what was the thing you just said I'm
saying that you know it's you don't want
to just be the only person yeah
critiquing yeah it is really important
it's really really important I think
yeah one of the things about that too is
trying to make the classroom I guess
kind of a safe space where people can be
really honest and you know it's like you
know what someone is probably going to
go at you and your work at some point
but you need to be okay with that and
you if you feel that you need to be
honest with somebody about their work
that's okay too as long as you're not
doing it on some kind of you know I you
know illegitimate grounds if you have if
it's a legitimate critique you should
feel okay about saying it yeah that's a
good point i think to their can it can
sometimes be helpful to just kind of lay
the ground rules of critique like what's
person I mean sometimes it's not obvious
to students like what's what's a
personal attack what's what's
constructive criticism of the work
sometimes people need yes I don't a peer
review yeah exactly and expect that
people know the rules I know luckily
just having Jamie at every single class
was really helpful and I I mean it's
hard like in an ideal world every class
would have a staff was like five people
who are all experts on different facets
of the industry and then a dedicated
instructional designer facilitating
group discussion every day to
instructors for right let's do this
right but you know what like that's what
it takes it really does because if Jamie
wasn't there like I don't know how to
facilitate classroom discussion I really
you know she would be able to interject
and sort of coach these things sublimity
subliminally without having to establish
like guys these are the classroom were a
little bit like no picking on people you
know like it was just all done very
organically and yeah and that's actually
very hard I mean I'm it is such a
cop-out answer to be like it's important
to foster a good classroom space go do
it you know but I
don't really know how to give actionable
items to people who are trying to do
this in their schools I think um one
thing I tried to do was and this was off
of Jamie suggestion was to do every
single assignment that I assigned to the
students so on day one when they had to
record a selfie pitch I did it and I was
like this is not perfect and the next
day I pointed out things that I didn't
like about it or things that could have
been better about my own work so I think
having something physical to be able to
critique to sort of show people how to
recruit a kit you know it's not even
just show people what's wrong but show
people the act of critiquing right oh
it's really important because if you
don't have the physical examples I mean
it's just like saying like lighting has
to be done well you know well I do you
don't show them an example of a well-lit
seen they're not going to be able to to
do this yeah the things you get from
from students who aren't used to giving
that kind of critique tend to be either
oh it was good or I didn't like it yeah
neither one of it is particularly
helpful they are invited writing class
students will be like this is really
deep yeah but then like to be able to be
there as an instructor and say okay why
do you think it yeah exactly why why is
it good why is it deep why didn't you
like it like the questions that drive
them to to give a more tangible answer I
mean that's really important in the live
discussion like yeah it and it's
important I think to have it in real
time which is why I don't know how you
can scale this experience up like if you
offer this as an online class for
instance like I guess you could have
forms where students critique each other
but again like without the guidance of
you know someone who's practiced it that
limits you and then you know someone who
responds like why do you think you know
this was deep like the next day he sort
of lose that momentum I mean the really
great thing is when when when this sort
of stuff happens on set like when we
were shooting the episode
the exploding wire and our student host
got to see you me and the director
photography get into a fight about why
we thought the framing was wrong and I
mean it was literally like what do you
think of this framing I hate it why
because it looks like an episode of home
improvement like an actual episode of
home improvement or the like show that
they were Perry parroting in home
improvement no the crappy version okay
well let's figure out how to fix it you
know like that's the kind of discussion
that happens on set yeah and that is so
much more helpful for someone to see
then sometimes people struggle with
framing here are some tips try to you
know put the people in this framing it
might be more engaging right like that's
sort of how media things are presented
right now but to see like George and me
fight is one way more entertaining but
to like I think like she probably took a
lot more out of that than I'm watching
like a lecture series